[Music]
a class this spring at Ohio State
University is dedicated to what it
clearly regards as the biggest problem
in a country with a lot of problems of
course it's straight white men be a man
masculinities race and nation is the
name of the class and it will needless
to say attack white men for their
privilege and a whole bunch of ways
readings have titles like advertising
and the construction of violent white
masculinity of course appears to revolve
around how white men have victimized
everybody else since the beginning of
time Christie sexually is the president
of new heights communication she's a
longtime Democrat who thinks deeply
about these issues and she joins us
tonight so here's my question Christy
without getting into just how
unbelievably awful every single straight
white man is I think that goes without
saying
as an electoral strategy this has become
really common on the Left even from
elected officials in the Democratic
Party dismissing white men is bad prima
facie bad isn't it kind of bad politics
to like tell tens of thousands hundred
thousands of people you hate them for
who they are like they're never gonna
vote for you why would you do that
so that Ohio State professor was not
tapped to write policy the last time I
checked right I don't see any policies
coming out of the Democratic Party that
are meant to demonize white men oh
really
so just I guess all of them beginning
with affirmative action and hiring set
asides and all that but but it's not
you're right some but it's not just Ohio
State the senior elected Democrat in the
House of Representatives last week
attacked the negotiations over daca only
because they were being led by quote
five white men as if that was like
inherently discrediting okay so that
that is something different and that is
something that I think that Trump brings
up for a lot of people which is that he
has in his 1 year in office already made
the least cabinet the least diverse
cabinet in a generation his court
appointments have been almost
exclusively white males something like
91 percent so if you look at that as a
woman you think hmm
now obviously white men are not the only
people on the planet I also don't
believe that they should be the only
people in positions of power but
President Trump does seem to feel this
way what
I don't know I mean if but you're not
supposed to attack people on the basis
of things they can't control like their
sex in the race those are the rules sure
and if all of a sudden you have elected
officials openly attacking people not
because of things they've said or things
they've done beliefs they have but on
the basis of their sex and race that's
profoundly alienating to people of the
same race and sex or maybe even other
people of good conscience do you see
right like maybe saying that people from
certain African countries or probably
could all be seen the same way and not
in a very positive way I don't think the
country whatever but I mean I guess if
you don't like that kind of talk then
why engage in it I guess that's my
that's my question I mean so naughty
things is not really an answer and this
is everywhere in the Democratic Party
and I've got a whole list of a
Democratic officials attacking white men
for being white men what's the idea here
what are you getting at they're not
attacking away from being white men
they're attacking the idea that things
are not diverse and that if we want to
actually have sincere conversations in
America about I don't know the way
things are and the way we can improve
our country then we actually have to
listen to more voices than just those
okay so here's Sally Boynton Browne she
was running for DNC chair she runs the
Democratic Party in a state in Idaho she
said my job is to be someone who shuts
up other white people shuts them down
really right so I remember that comment
and that was kind of a stupid comment
but what she meant by that was sometimes
the people in power need to just sit
back and do some listening as opposed to
all the talking and am i what she's
saying
not every white man is in power in fact
the life expectancy for a lot of white
men is going down that's not true for
any other group mm-hmm a lot of women
who have no power at all in fact they're
dying younger than other people so I
guess it's the the assumption that
because of your race and sex you somehow
have power is itself the definition of
racist I think we both agree so why say
that crap in public like what's the
point of it I again I think that that
was a pretty dumb statement that she
made but again the sentiment behind it I
think is one that we can agree with
which is that you know sometimes the
people in power need to be doing the
listening instead of the talking well I
completely agree with that I mean I feel
that way about Nancy Pelosi use held
power for too long and she can and
listen but
not about her race or sex bottom line
how can a party that attacks people on
the basis of their race expect to win
any votes from those people is there a
calculation again I don't believe that
the Democratic Party does attack people
on the basis of their race I think
that's actually something that we've
seen a lot from the Republican Party Wow
we may be living a different Christi
thank you for joining us Thank You
Tucker